our Veterans Day Parade took place this
morning in downtown Las Vegas Joshua
piguerra spoke to those who turned out
sharing just how important it is to
thank those who serve
flags were waving as well as hands as
folks lined up along 4th Street to watch
veterans and other groups March I do
appreciate all the freedom that we have
As Americans and we're out here to
support there were military vehicles
vintage cars and motorcycle groups on
the parade route members of the National
Association of Buffalo Soldiers and
troops motorcycle club were part of the
procession it's up to us to like keep
kind of keep that Legacy going to keep
the keep the tradition alive
motorcycling and Military go hand in
hand and they always have since the
Inception of the motorcycle the Buffalo
Soldiers were the first all-black
peacetime regiment established by
Congress made up of former slaves free
men and Civil War soldiers I think over
the years a good job of letting people
know about the 9th and 10th Cavalry and
the other all black units that were
created post-civil War veterans Action
Group plans the annual parade touted as
the largest Veterans Day Parade held
west of the Mississippi several of the
people that we spoke to say it was
important to show up in order to honor
those who served in our military and
with less than one percent of the
American population currently serving
they say this should serve as a calling
card for those younger populations these
kids need to realize that things aren't
given to them anymore you know if it
wasn't for our military none of us would
have this Luis Ramirez brought his two
young grandchildren along to instill in
them some of these American values we
got to teach him about you know that
what used to happen in the past and
showing that that what's new in the
future lessons that he hopes they pass
along to their kids in Las Vegas Joshua
pereiro 8 News Now